[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHENAZ ZACK: Today as I
stand in front of you,
I'm humbled and honored to
introduce an amazing line
of speakers and workshops.
ANIYIA WILLIAMS: You
deserve to be here.
In fact you deserve to be
in any room that you're in
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I'm here to tell you,
if you didn't already know
from this incredible day
together is that the future,
yes indeed, is female.
KARISHMA SHAH: When you
see a glimmer of madness
in people's eyes when they
speak about what they do,
pull up a chair and let them
transport you to their world.
KYLE EWING: You take the
time to compile that story,
and then you actually
share that story,
it's going to help bring
others into the work
that you're doing,
and ultimately,
make for a much larger impact.
DIANA TRUJILLO:
There's no way on earth
that I ever thought that
this Latina girl who
didn't know any
English will end up
as like senior management of
the technical aspect of a Rover
on Mars.
KIM HUNTER: Give
yourself permission
to explore who you are,
and what your passions are,
and what you want to do.
HILLARY HARTLEY: If you can
bring up the courage to ask,
I guarantee you
someone will say yes.
CHRISTINE KAESER-CHEN:
There's so much more
we can do to not just organize
the world's information,
but to gather the
world's experiences,
and make them universally
accessible and useful.
MO FONG: So we're
announcing three new careers
with Code Expeditions today.
And they are stellar
amazing women,
who have used technologies
in so many interesting ways
in their fields.
BROOKE BASINGER: Take risks, set
your sights on something big,
talk somebody into
letting you do it.
JULIE TIZARD: You
put the right amount
of people, and the
right talent of people,
with the right passion on
a job, you can pretty much
achieve anything.
MARIAN CROAK: There is a
growing number of universities
that are beginning to report
that computer science majors
and engineers are almost
50% female gives me
a tremendous sense of optimism.
LISETTE TITRE-MONTGOMERY: Seeing
more women and women of color
will let the next generation
know what is possible.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's going
to take each and every one
of us pulling up the
rest of us to build
the sisterhood at the top.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: All
of you in this room,
think about the power you have,
the networking, the connections
you can build, and own it.
Own the work, own where
you are, own your mistakes,
and own the path forward.
[MUSIC PLAYING]